are you are you cutting back on sugar i
do need to i'm reading a book about it
because i do think i'm addicted to sugar
so
i eat ice cream every night
and
it's so much ice cream i like ketchup i
like to use enough ketchup that the
person next to me has to go man that's a
lot of ketchup
like that's
they have to
they have to feel like they got it they
get involved and they're like that's a
lot isn't it i'm like is it i don't know
wow i'm not yeah i don't uh i eat i ate
gummy bears last night in the hotel and
i didn't want to
but i love them so much
and it's terrible i love uh
french toast and pancakes and i eat it
every day and it makes me so tired
i don't know and i never blamed the
pancakes i'm like what is whoop today
man like i
i guess i didn't get sleep last night